so been looking at your IMDB you were
born in 1988 you love John Hughes movies
and John Hughes was already making films
by this time where does this love for a
tease films come and do you feel you
were born at the wrong time I used to
say in the past that i was born in the
wrong time because i used to love the
60s so much but as I grew up I just I
think it was like five or six years ago
I just fell into this love for 80s
movies like I mean my all-time favorite
are John Carpenter William Friedkin
journeys these kind of people who use
the Jarrah the general film as a way to
convey a story to as a starting point to
just tell a bigger story I love how and
the current brothers are still doing
that for me the compressors still doing
Kenneth in the 80s genre kind of cinema
and i love the way in da it is the genre
was a starting point to tell much bigger
stories story with political
implications or metaphysical
implications for me i remember the movie
gotcha yeah yeah yeahs aren t know and
anthony edwards and even though it was
about serious subject there was still an
element of play right and I missed that
about so many films that's that's so
true i mean especially the blockbusters
in the studio movies in the 80s used to
have these playfulness as you were
saying which i think relates to I mean
nowadays where we are in a postmodern
age where I mean a lot of filmmakers are
kind of obnoxious by making movies the
because some of them are aware of that
but I think that some of them are not
because it's also we live in a time
where I mean we have cinematics and
places where we see a lot of movies old
movies all the time and I think that
cinema of course is becoming more and
more now and we are restoring preserving
movies and it can be cumbersome some
time because we feel like we are
standing standing on the shoulders of
giants you know of the people who came
before us and that's true that I love
the eighties movies in a way because
they were so playful and they were so
not pretentious at all I mean when you
look at back at the the the blood
vessels of the eighties they were not so
pretentious and that's why I think like
a movie for example like guardians of
the galaxy right now is doing so well at
the box office because it has this kind
of not I mean not rebel spirit but I
mean it has these playfulness and these
not pretentious aspect to it even though
I even though you you can like it or not
like this movie but you have to
recognize that it has this playfulness
that Hollywood cinema and blockbusters
used to have in the 80s seems like to
there was a lot of cameos right people
and sometimes they weren't even really
stars they were just known yeah for
being like in movies and like you never
really knew what they did yeah but so do
you do you miss that do you think I mean
we still see it somewhat today but maybe
with you know a musician but does that
something that also treat you yeah I
mean I mean we were talking about John
news I it was not in Breakfast Club I
think it was it was in Ferris Bueller
the Cameo of Charlie Sheen I mean is
amazing it's like I mean the image of
charging in this perfecto leather you
know jacket is like standing in the
camera it's it's so it's so funny in and
he's on camera for like five or ten
seconds no more and yeah I love this
idea of coming back to Gen use and these
camp directors who had this group of
people of actors following them and just
working with them and they could call
them and just proposed Emma cameo just a
small thing into a movie do you want to
bring that back i mean i think in was it
staying alive Sly Stallone yeah bumps
into John
Travolta and like the opening shot right
you know it so great yeah is that
something that you want to incorporate
just there's an element of play even
though it was a serious films day one
yeah i loved this playfulness and from
me to us it's something i love these
blockbusters back in the day where this
playfulness this this game with the the
audience and this way of just getting
the audience in and playing with them
along yes so i think nowadays it's
sometimes a lot of blood vessels and in
even indie movies I mean a lot of movies
right now I think are really sometimes
too too aware of what they are doing is
it's like they have to make references
and they have to be serious like and I
mean I love I mean for me the line of
Joker and the Indian Krishna land the
dark nights like why so serious it could
be it could apply also to moviemaking
right now and it's moving making is
getting I think too serious I mean it's
like it's so serious you want to say
like make some joke I mean to take a
joke and just laugh at it I mean to make
a process even more fun for the audience
so I think we lost will I mean we lost
the fun part of making movies I mean a
lot of people lost it and you can feel
that in the movies so you made a thesis
film entitled who frame the movie critic
right and we were talking earlier about
how in France a movie critic has so much
power how do you feel movie critics
should be regarded and do you submit
your films to be critiqued I enjoy a lot
critics and and I um I want to have more
and more feedbacks about what I do so of
course I'm I'm not the kind of guy i'm
going to say you don't know nothing so
don't talk about a movie I love having
the most people i can about
movies and I think that what a lot of
critics would need to have is more a
knowledge of how you make a movie I mean
how we make a movie and it's I mean I
think that a lot of critics have these
these theories they have this knowledge
this great knowledge but movies like
from the expression is German cinema to
nowadays bloggers stars they have these
great knowledge but I think that a lot
of them lack a sense of craft of
filmmaking I think and that's what
struck me when I made the jump from
creating myself to director is that not
a lot of people know the craft of
filmmaking and I think that I don't
consider myself as an artist and I don't
consider filmmaker as artists but more
as craftsmen and I think that I mean
it's like it's like carpenters I mean
it's like it's it's something you just
go with your hands at your bare hands
and just work on a set it's very
physical it's I think that's why it's
more of a craft and I think that a lot
of critics don't have this knowledge of
the craft of filmmaking so you studied
to be a film critic or that was your
hopes yeah exactly i studied to be from
critic I've been a film critic for wide
and friends and i heed I realized that
it was a conservative choice for me to
do that and I really wanted to be a
director forever to make my movies and
not only talk about other people's
movies so I made jump and I decided no
you have to make movies and tell the
stories your way where did you study in
France so yeah in France I studied a
movie critic unless Obama to be I
studied journalism at La Sorbonne and
with this idea of me
he wanting to be a film critic so yeah
it was a lesser one do you remember the
day or a few incidents when you said you
know what this isn't for me well I have
a lot of moments like that where I sit
myself it's not for me I uh I was a lot
younger and maybe a base now when I look
back maybe a bit back in in the days
obnoxious but what I wanted to do was
like I wanted to make movies and and I
was didn't make a clear choice I said I
wanted to make movies and artistical
stuff but i was still learning to be a
quick so i was in at the crossroads of
the two of them and i didn't make clear
choice so i can say that every single
time i was going to make an interview to
make a report and movie interview
filmmakers actors all that stuff I every
single time was like I want to be on the
other side and I want to tell my stories
because that's what I want to do and so
yeah pretty much all the time then to
answer your question I've been thinking
about that so having been in the States
for a few years now how do you see
American movie critics regarded versus
French movie critics I like the fact
that a lot of American movie critics are
not that big of a deal rather than in
Paris it's not French is in Paris Paris
is a little town really and the the
people who are in charge of movie
producing and movie with your reviewing
our kind of the same people and they are
frequenting each other and it's it's a
small group of people which is not an
insult for me it's their way of doing it
but I think here in the u.s. there is
this tradition of its I mean in France
it's more hello it's closer to being a
friend to people and being able to
interview them rather than here there is
more of a craft of movie critics I mean
when you look at Roger Ebert even though
Roger Ebert get famous because of his
relentless sometimes harsh critics but
movies our amazing critic of movies I
think he he managed to to understand
what the craft of finicky was because
himself he wrote a movie for four I
think watch a comment he wrote the in
the valley of dolls and so so he had
this idea you knew what movie making and
writing was about so I think that here
in the US it's more of a profession
where as in France and Paris it's also
profession but it's also something which
is for them seen by themselves as as as
of an artistic form in French movie
critics are seeing them personally
themselves as artists too in a way and
they have to make the critic feel like
it is an artistic form so sometimes this
idea of just I'm gonna write something
as artistical as the movie is against
the critic of itself because it's I
think it's running what a movie Creek
should be about which which is stripping
down the filmmaking process and see what
where the choice is made by the director
do you think all potential movie critics
or current movie critics should be
required to at least make one feature
film uh that's that would be good idea
but I think that would not be possible
for a lot of them but I mean I think
that I mean I there are a lot of them
who are going on a set and and once you
are in a set you understand
bit more what it is but that's true that
when you are not on the in the chair of
the of the director you cannot feel and
you cannot understand what it is about
so yeah if to say there would be a need
for them to to know what the craft is
more about so yeah maybe going on the
set directing shorts just taking some
classes maybe editing yeah yeah editing
is awesome yes yeah in the Ingraham you
are truly that's where you are feeling
that you have to make choices and and
she's makings about making choices and
cutting a lot of stuff so yeah I think
they will need that how long have you
thought about being a filmmaker you're
26 now right so do you remember how old
you were when you decided i want to make
films it was um it was right after high
school that when i entered lesser one as
I I knew that I wanted to do that but
when you in France when you finish high
school there is no clear way of just
being a filmmaker win so when you are
anything I think in the u.s. it's kind
of blurry also that's a gray area I mean
when you are graduating I mean I mean
nobody knows really how you enter a film
school or what are the film schools are
there I think that which is kind of
crazy because I think filmmaking should
be treated as a job as a real job like
other jobs and we should show maybe the
kids okay so you can go that way and
learn that and go into this school and
learn the craft there and I think that
we it's a common thing here and maybe in
the US and Europe and everywhere that we
lack a clear path to go
and be a movie director I mean when you
have a key to say I love movies I want
to make movies a lot of the time they
don't know where to go which is that I
think so why do you make films what's
the reason I make fins because I am
addicted to fianza and I want to make
stories that people can be addicted to
like I used to be and like I am right
now with the other people's movies I
think okay it's all about the story but
it's so also about creating a universe
where people can go back with their mind
a lot of time they can like I wish
people making movies for people to go
back at night and when they are about to
sleep think about the movie and think
about its characters think about its
universe and just I want a movie to
steal be with them and to accompany them
have to go in life you talked about
going to school near a bunch of us you
know movie theaters when you walk in
when you pay your twelve dollars or
whatever it is correct what do you want
from a movie what do you want for it to
do for you you mean right now our
beckenham either way yeah you sit in
that chair you're like you know what
I've committed to two hours of my time
right i paid the money i have my popcorn
or whatever it is what do you want that
movie to do for you I want the movie to
make me feel something truly I want to
feel happy sad i want i want to feel
something physical at you I mean most of
the films i truly love provoked
something visceral in me i want to feel
that visceral thing in me i mean i want
to be crushed i want to be
I i dream i mean when i feel like a
human being I think that's the goal at
the end of the day and that's why most
of the films I and filmmakers I true
love use this visceral aspect of film
which is from me one of the most
important oh ok film is a cerebral
cerebral thing sometime but for me and
that you kind of seem I want to do I
want to do something more primitive more
visceral something which can stick with
people like Blue Valentine yeah thats
daily yeah exactly took you on just a
roller coaster of emotions yeah I
thought we were gonna say blue belly
which is also sure yet yes I'm issues
david lynch fan so how do you see the
artists regarded in france vs the US you
know you talked about there was that
great time right after high school
around that time when you're making that
decision do you think the artist is
embraced as much in the US as it is in
in france or even in europe i would just
make a note about that because I think
that filmmakers I mean are not that's
why artists I think I mean I think that
small of a craft artist I would say that
would be more people painters I mean
sculptures these kind of people I think
that it we don't have to lose the
industry side and the craft of it and
it's true that in France it's seen as
enough as a very artistically which is
great sometimes but in other times which
can be also cumbersome because you have
this like when you I mean when people
tell you okay you are an artist you have
to make an artistic a movie sometimes it
can make people overthink and over
killed movie and and that's why I love
in the u.s. these craft which you are
sharing with the DP with your ad with
producers and you are constructing a
movie
together with your bare hands as well as
i was telling you and I love this
concrete physical way of building the
movie almost as the same physical form
that the viewers are going to feel it in
a very visceral way so you're a
craftsperson yeah exactly that's how I
would define myself and that I love this
term because you have a long tradition
of in the sort of man kind of people of
carpenters of people building cathedrals
I mean when we make a movie of course
it's not as building a cathedral but in
a way it's kind of a small Cathedral you
have to build it so and you're affecting
people yeah like you said cuz there's
movies that stay with us for years that
have changed us exactly exactly I want
to fake people and I think that it's not
only a trick because some people I love
for example the way a crystal and
described his movies is like is a
magician it's like building things for
people and i love it i love this side
this craft tricking side where people
don't know how the movie was made which
is amazing and yeah for me it's all
about that and but not to trick people
it's to trick people to make to make
them feel something then how did you
know you were ready to make a feature
film
I I didn't think about that you know
what I maybe I was not ready I just
actually I just went out and made the
film and that i think came from an
impulsive jest I wanted to make my
feature film so I didn't think about
anything and we just went and made the
movie and that's after the film the
shooting itself that you realize hmm I
we just did that in a crazy amount of
time I mean we were so fast and we just
and at the end it was like it was like a
train going and just going so fast and
we were just jumping on the train and
just and just when a train stopped we're
like whoa we've been doing all these
throw together and we didn't realized
about that i mean because it was so fast
and so and I think that's a great thing
because sometimes when you are thinking
too much but making movie you can you
can kill it by over thinking and taking
too much time in the at the end not
making a movie where r us with my
co-producer Todd bar too and our actors
we just went and make the movie what was
that first thing that you did cuz i know
you were taking the filmmaking class at
UCLA Extension right and you were
supposed to make a short but you said
you know what I think I want to make a
feature exactly so the thesis film at
UCLA was about was supposed to be 15
minutes long and I over the course of
two month is I just wrote in rewrote and
rewrote and rewrote this pink zone
scraped and I knew I want you to make
that and so I went and see them and I
asked them ok so can I can I use the
first act the first 15-minute act as my
thesis fiamma and let me do the rest the
future of him for myself and they were
like okay and so after that we just when
I
make the movie and made the movie which
was which was 70 pages long so and but I
knew a lot of it was going to be based
on improv because I love to work with
improv meritor so IBM at the end of the
day we have a one hour and 32 minutes
long movie which is the perfect feet for
the movie what were some of the first
steps you took I mean did you go to
actors access and put up a casting
notice or what did you okay so the first
thing was to secure locations because we
had these I were discreet in a way that
could be possible to do in real life and
and so we were able to secure the avenue
of the stars for example for one day of
shoot and I wouldn't seed people at UCLA
which was tough to secure because even
though I was a student at UCLA extension
will still student UCLA it's still super
hard to get authorization and permits
and because they're more into
authorizing shows like CSI so so great
shows and kind of great indie movies
like I don't like likes to do indie
movies tugging and not no budget so it
was kind of a hard but because we talked
but the story and bout what I wanted to
do and what locations I needed they were
fine with it and so after locations at
the same time as locations we started
the what for me was the most important
process which is the casting the
audition process and for me that was the
most important because since i knew i
was going to rely a lot on improv and
indeed to have the right people and
because these stories a character-driven
story before all i knew that my
characters my actors would have to carry
the film
and and at the end I knew that they
would be creating the film as me as I
was doing on said so so I auditioned
these people here at film independent
and we had two days of fool auditions
and we so almost 1,000 people and was
crazy tons of people boys and girls from
for the boys and girls roles and each
time we I mean all these people were
hired because I had a true I fell in
love with them for the characters they
were the right character and so it was
it wasn't fun and very enjoyable process
I love auditioning guessing it's great
because you meet these people who are
going to bring something else to the
game to the character I mean a lot of
people brought so much of the character
of that at the end of the day the
character changed and so that was the
most beautiful thing I think I think you
were on another film show and the guy
said man I fall in love with my lead
actress every time I forget what it was
but he said like for that movie you
become so engrossed and you fall in love
with those characters yeah once it's
done you're just you're on to the next
thing exactly exactly back to normal
life we have to say goodbye it's done
and I think the most for me the big
revelation was the male lead of the film
dad which is played by Matt Cooper who
is the father of the lead actress of
bings own and so basically I had a hard
time finding my dad my dad character so
so during these two days I couldn't find
anyone who was dad so I was like I'm
gonna be I'm gonna have to bring some
other people so I did another afternoon
of additions for dad at UCLA on
peace and so we had like 30 other people
coming I was like and it was still not
finding the right dad and then came this
guy Matt Cooper this a great actor and
who just brought this humanistic side of
dad because daddy in my script was too
much of a bad guy I kind of nut clichy
because and they want him to be cliche
but I mean it was thrilled bad guy and
when Matt came in the audition he
brought that human side of that and it
was like how he is making these bad
choices but he has good intentions and
that's something I didn't see in my own
script and when Matt came in and brought
this on table I was like this is perfect
this is who that is so I hired him right
away and was happy where are you posting
these casting notices we used a funeral
we used a la casting the website la
casting which as these I mean
everybody's in on LA casting which is
great so it's perfect we had huge huge
responses and and all these people were
I wanted these people to I was not going
to look for what they've been doing in
the past I'm not this kind of guy who
look in the back of the resume I'm all
I'm more looking in front of the resume
and what they're doing actually in front
of me and and that's why I I knew that I
wanted to have people who are fresh in a
way and would have not been on the
circuit of indie films too much I wanted
them to be fresh and creative and I try
some stuff on said so so that's why most
of them had not so many credits I mean
some of them had some good Kraze but
none of them had big credits and that
was the great thing because they were
fresh
these new faces they were not a Famers
and and for me that was the most three
part of it why make a feature why not
stick with shorts right you you had to
make this feature why what was it to be
honest I I was talking about that with a
professor of mine at UCLA who is with
the correct prediction penny who is a
veteran in a hand and anyways like don't
make a feature wants you you're out of
him school film school is great place to
make short and I did a bunch of shorts
at UCLA to learn i was i was learning
like that but it's true that one advice
I would have is don't lose time on doing
shorts I mean there are so many people
there who are making films and killing
themselves directors that I think that
the right now times have changed it's
not like it used to be with the
Spielberg Lucas who get famous because
of their shorts and get access to bigger
frame because of their shorts nowadays I
mean we are in the time of digital
cinema and getting pretty usable camera
is pretty cheap you can even do it with
your iPhone and so it's all about people
are going to judge if you are able to
hold a long time and be able to make a
true feature film so I was like I don't
want to make it short anymore so let's
do a feature film and this is after how
many shorts I did three or four shots at
UCLA okay so you were saying yeah this
is it yeah this is but i think i'm
paraphrasing here something that you
said but to the effect that of the
beauty of cinema is showing a character
that has failed or has flaws and you
said that as a movie go or this is what
you love about films why why does that
intrigue you yeah i mean for me one of
my all-time favorite character in
fiction would be
the Walter White that's I'm such a huge
and breaking bad and the great thing is
is not a bad guy per se I mean he's
making of course bad decision and acts
along the Surrey the series but I mean
in the first two episodes you understand
who this guy he is and you understand
that he wants to leave he wants to feel
live again in and that's why I mean you
can that's why this character is has
been taking all these viewers with him
on this kind of crazy route to the end
of the show because people were able to
follow him anywhere because we're all
water white and we're all wanting to get
bail life who want to feel live and I
think that that's what I felt with the
character of dad link by Matt Cooper
that I felt that this guy wanted to be
loved and wanted to have a good living
and and of course his actions to get
that are bad really bad but where it
comes from it's something that is a
universal and that's why people were
running with the water white I mean I
mean the crazy thing is at the end of
the series you were you're like oh he's
been doing so many bad stuff and I think
that we were not realizing because we
were so much empathizing with him
because of what is being through and
what he really wanted to have in life
the kissing for me is when in the first
season when he just he has his big break
with the the drug dealer to co mean is
like is blowing the whole place up and
then he has his money in the car is like
yelling and he's it feels alive and I
think for me that's the epicenter of
what characters on screen should be and
what I love to see it about them so you
wouldn't want to see like let's suppose
this this perfect guy who's got the the
supermodel wife and drives this great
for scar and never gets mad and has this
like perfect Zen attitude it's not
that's not appealing well actually
that's that's pretty appealing to I mean
in a way I think about the wolf of Wall
Street well it's not is not Leonardo
DiCaprio is not that then in the movie
but i love the way also this guy wants
to also feel alive and he has is a true
bad guy but he it's so I mean he's a
wolf because he he wants something which
she's visceral and I think which has
existed since dawn of time in human
nature and so I think as long as
screenwriters are able to make any
character with it can be a loser or a
multi-millionaire I mean any character
if the writer is able to make us relate
to him through a something visceral I
think it's it should be something with
this or something we which is something
we all aspire to have dens down then it
then the part i mean the the match is
wrong I mean you have one as soon as the
audience can root for this guy and
because they are feeling what this guy
is feeling then would you call yourself
competitive
I don't have a competitive nature uh but
uh but it's I thinking but I'm
competitive with myself I would say I'm
I love challenges for myself I'm giving
myself tons of challenges all the time
and that I think that's the most fun and
that's the great thing it's not about
competing with other people that just
competing with yourselves and in in
elevating the bar and just trying to
reach for for more and more and for this
movie I was challenging myself to
writing writing it in such an amount of
time shooting it in such an amount of
time we shot in 12 days and and the day
before the last day we shot an eight
page is seen in two hours for me I
moviemaking is like the ultimate team
sport and it's so about challenging
yourself and the other people who are
working with you so when we shut these
eight pages seen in two hours it felt so
good at the end of day because we had
everything we wanted to have when didn't
need anything more and it was something
which we couldn't do any longer because
we had the location at UCLA for this
amount of time and we knew that we
couldn't stay any minute longer so we
had these what people could see as a
pressure for me is is it's a limit but I
love limits limits from either way to
get a way around it and make it happen
and and the Sun was going down so we had
only two hours and we made it happen
because everybody on set every actor
every crew was doing their job they were
right in their position and we just shot
and we got it so competition within
yourself yeah where does that come from
I think that comes from me as a viewer
also i love when I love bravura when
filmmakers just transcend a story and go
beyond beyond intellectual or limits or
go beyond scientifical stuff or go
beyond what filmmaking is beyond just
using a camera as a tool i mean i love
that's why people go and see gravity i
mean when you are you are in gravity you
are in the movie you these long texts
are not something for the sake of doing
long takes it's something which elevates
the story and bring you in the story as
if you were so I love the challenges as
a way to get better stories and to to
get to get better images to get better
words to throw people into do you have a
trait of getting things done I see that
about you seeing you get things done
yeah I that's that's my motto that we
might borrow to make it work and to get
things down especially in movie set you
have to you have to get things done
otherwise there nobody is going to help
you I mean as the director that's the
role the set is a chaotic place is very
caring place and it's a dangerous place
also e and that's I think what a lot of
people who have not been in said no no
but movie said it's a dangerous place
and that's a caring place and as a movie
maker I think our role is to manage
chaos and stew and to keep people
focused and to show the way and to get
things done even though so many weird
crazy stuff can happen in the set you
have to keep I mean you
you are the commander of a boat you have
to keep going then you said earlier that
being a director is being a captain of a
ship and managing chaos I understand
that one of your actresses was out of
commission so how did that happen and
how did you not let everything fall
apart or maybe it did for a day right
okay so we had the we intended to shoot
the movie in 12 days which I did the day
we did but with the one month stop in
production so the thing is we shudder
six first days of shoot and then our
lead actress broke her collarbone on set
which of course in the moment was a sad
thing to go through for all of us
because we were so any together and you
know what actually to get back and said
it was pretty easy I remember that I
mean the lead actress wanted to go back
so bad because she was so committed and
everyone was so committed that I think I
we went back and I sent an email like
five days only after that asking for
people would be available in one month
to n and people were like be all the
actors and all the crew was so committed
and involved to tell the story and they
lacked the first part of the movie so
much that they were like of course we
want to go back and so we will just wait
then within one month and people went
back and said and we did the six other
days of shoot one
after so pretty much it was it was
actually simple to get everybody back
and said because people people were so
it was such a cohesive mood I mean
atmosphere and people were so committed
to telling the story that of course they
wanted to finish the story to tell the
story how did you handle it when let so
so I'm assuming she went to the hospital
and you don't know what's happening you
didn't know how maybe how committed
everyone was right so that 24 hours or
however long how are you dealing with
that it was a juicy both her and pain
and to see the film stopped it's like
the two most awful pain pains but I have
such a nature of just overcoming things
that I was I put myself into the future
and I was like okay we have to make it
work and we have to start rearing the
film toward its end and so yeah we I I
had this yeah I'd say less than 24 hours
moment of doubt of course but I because
the instinct was to finish the film I
just decided to just go beyond it to go
beyond doubt and the pain and just to
get everybody on board again so your
advice to another filmmaker that right
it sounds like when you're all in on
something you're like a hundred and ten
percent exactly exactly yeah there's no
Sami so what's your advice to another
filmmaker that maybe doesn't have that
strong of a resolve but could if they
had the right pep talk sure well don't
let go of anything just don't stop
anything there is nothing which will
stop your movie if you have the right
people with you so be sure who you have
in your crew in your cast but especially
in your crew have good and legitimate
producer
have a good and legitimate line producer
have a great first ad which you can tell
anything to and who will do anything for
the sake of the movie to help you go
through this road so it's I mean in la
there are a lot of people call
themselves producers because they have
like this small credit like on a TV or
some of the stuff or don't even have
anything and just stay away from that
and I know that finding the legitimate
people takes time and and that's the
hardest part if you have legitimate
people board you will fail and even if
you are somebody who is a great soul
lining and tries to overcome everything
if you have a legitimate a legitimate
people and i'm not talking about only
bad vibrations or these kind of stuff
with unprofessional people you won't
make it so be sure of who you have in
your crew be sure of who you have in
your cast and then it it would be pretty
easy to follow up with this kind of crew
and cast how many days did you work on
the pigs own script i started working on
the idea in the concept of the film
shaping the concept in march 2013 and i
wrote the first draft i think it was in
april 2013 so you had a whole month of
just shaping the concept and getting to
this idea of a virus transmitted by men
to women and deadly women and and for me
I knew this theme should come from a
concept like it used to be the 80s you
know like this high-concept movie and I
knew that was the former I wanted to
have the FEMA and then as soon as I had
a concept it went pretty quick I mean
into Monday's I had two month is between
the first drive
and the final draft so I would say April
to may 2013 so your first draft who do
you let read it no one literally no Anna
no I because I the first part for me is
I mean I think in first draft in here in
everything is bad I mean it's like the
first edit the rough edit it's going to
be bad all the time that was a telescope
maker and Martin Scorsese I mean
marriage cases is a editor who said it
the first the rough edit is crap and it
is like the first draft of course and
when I went back there like oh how could
I wrote that and that's part of the of
the way it is and then the second draft
I started to show it to a group of
people I bring in in I brought in sorry
into a writers group i form the writers
group and but that was only from the
second or third draft so yeah I started
rewriting the first draft myself and
then boom bringing back people I could
trust to give me input all that stuff
and then reworking reworking reworking
rewriting rewriting again and again and
again again until that point where at
the end it felt ready and ready to show
to other people so so yeah that's I
think you shouldn't show a first draft
to anyone rewrite rewrite rewrite before
showing another draft to people where do
you do your best writing is it at home
or out I for this film I wrote a lot in
coffee shops then from me it was great
because I needed to have this life
around me to help me put life into my
characters
whoo and also it was a way to ground
these people into reality because I
wanted to the movie to look as realistic
as it could and I know sometimes from me
the great the greater risk would have
been to step aside from reality and I
think sometimes that's something which
happened lot 22 scraped to completely
forget about reality where this story is
happening who are these characters where
they are living in and and for me being
able to read it I mean not rewriting it
but I mean writing some of the stuff in
in in coffee shops is bringing me this
life and and making me remember that
life is all around us and these people
should be alive and working around as
well as we are speaking and so I came up
with the backstory of every single
character because of that and for me I
wanted every single character to feel
like before these great virus appeared
on earth they had life which was totally
different and they had jobs which were
totally different they came from places
which are totally different and that's
why writing it into coffee shops for me
used I mean made me more aware of the
reality of it so this writer's group
that you formed were they also bringing
in their original material to or this
was just to look over your like a script
read they were bringing their own
material to so we gave a look to their
material too but i have to say we spent
a lot of time most of the time talking
about pink zone and which was truly
insane because you have these people
working from totally different places
and has totally different sensibilities
to film so it could have been like blood
blister and auteur films so this mix of
inputs about the script
allowed me to be aware of other people
out there who would watch the film and
and they should get in the story also so
that was great do you reward or punish
yourself if you don't sit down at the
computer or if you don't go to whatever
the coffee shop is and then vice versa
no I know I think that's more of an
organic process just ok for pingel I
have to say I frost myself I forced
myself to just go there and write and
write and rewrite yeah I for myself and
I would say that the next one I'm
writing right now has I want to write it
in a totally different way I'm running
into a different way which is a story
I'm more which is with me and I'm more
taking time to get everything matured
within my mind I want to every character
to have its own life in my mind and
write it later on as everybody would
have this life of their own in my mind
so yeah I mean it's so I'm trying this
new this new way of writing it which is
also as good and less stressful life to
say because it's true that when you have
because i knew i needed to go into
production in July so I knew that I
couldn't mess up with anything and I had
to just write it and almost in a Roger
common kind of way in in the
exploitation movie I was like I need to
write it and I had these date so I
couldn't just take my time like I'm
doing right now to just let the
characters live in my mind I had this
time limit which in a way is great
because it forces you to write then
where do you see filmmaking 10 to 20
years from now uh
that's that's a good one that's uh I
think it's all about immersion the
viewer into into the stories more and
more that's why we're seeing gravity and
feeling like that and that's why people
tried the 3d but 3d was a fad so I mean
it's 3d is not going to exist anymore
sit but the goal is still acting for for
movies to immerse people into the story
whether it is on a blog burster format
like gravity literally putting this
viewer in a movie and even I think for
some Indies I mean it's all about
immersion in terms of creating places
and atmospheres and moves that the
viewer is going to get immersed into and
and so I think both a studio film making
an indie filmmaking are looking for the
same kind of thing I hope which is
immersion and that's why there are so
many great ways of getting there which I
think are not even created yet I mean
all the stuff that James Cameron is is
preparing for his next avatar avatar
movies in LA I mean it's like II you can
either love it or hate it I understand
that some people don't believe in that
or hate these kind of filmmaking but you
have to recognize that this guy for
example is a total pioneer and is making
things progress and for the sake of a
store each time and so I get I think
that immersion has always been since the
dawn of moviemaking the motto for four
from movie makers and I think that
immersion will still be the goal and how
can we go to more immersion would that
be this new screening systems that the
focus is a trying right now which is
three screens at the same time it's a
brand new screening system which is
going to arrive a thing soon in some
theaters in the US which is a which is
truth which is three screens to one on
each side and one in front which is kind
of a Dolby Surround applied to to film
which is which is I know it sounds kind
of weird but I mean let's right let's
see how it goes so there is this kind of
cinema there is the the all digital
capture cinema where you have this
camera which you are pointing everywhere
into a digital world so basically the
cameraman is pointing into the world and
you're seeing where you are shooting and
you have so many great forms which are
developing so I think the future is
going to be bright grand new forms some
some fats like like the 3d which are
going to be talked about for a year and
then nobody's going to talk about it
anymore but some of these techniques are
going to stay and I think that's that's
great because even us right now as indie
filmmakers we can find great ways to get
the audience even more into the story
and the movie business 10 to 20 years
from now one thing which would be which
is SATA is I think right now there is a
I mean of course I'm the first one to
say that was what George Lucas and
Spielberg were saying about there is a
gap which is accentuating between blog
browsers and an indie films and that's
true that indie film films are getting
even more indie and even more recluse
two people and and blog Bursar's are
also getting even more focused on only
superhero movies so you get like it's
kind of sad to see these two poles
getting a part in a way but because I'm
an optimistic person I think there are a
lot of ways to bring the two together
again like if you're looking at
christopher nolan i was telling you I
the most brilliant indie filmmaker and
blend and studio filmmaker and he's
doing this the two at the same time I
mean movies like inception of the Dark
Knight were done in a very indie way I
mean with is DP Willy Feaster they come
from this world and they know how to
this shoot in a very independent way
even though they are making the biggest
budget of their time and so that's why I
think there are people like that who can
do this both at the same time how did
you get pink zone into your first film
festival so pings and headings were
premiere at the identity film festival
which truly is an amazing festival which
is one of the biggest indie film
festival in LA and we had this other
work we had the word premiere to change
theater so it was such a great moment
and the people there the founders of the
festival Leslie scallon and Michael
Trent are just too amazing film lovers
and they are some of the greatest people
I met so far in this business they are
remaking and they managed to create this
vessel which get even bigger and bigger
with the time and still maintained its
connection with filmmakers and the
audience so so from me the choice of
going with them and when I received
their notification that they wanted to
have to screen the movie to be part of
the official selection I was like of
course we want to go with you because
they has
this Great Spirit about them there is
this great spirit about them and they
love movies and they make you feel like
it so it's great so the other festivals
that you've chosen to submit how did you
choose them and do you ever ask them to
waive fees and I mean it's a lot yeah it
is a lot and I I know some people are
seen to waive fees I personally
especially at the beginning of the first
of all circuit I was not being
comfortable with asking like oh do this
for free to me because I understand that
especially if you are into indie
filmmaking you can understand and relate
to independent festivals and the way I
mean they need to make a living and to
to show you even more movies they need
to have this phone so for me paying the
fees even though sometimes it can be
brutal because it's kind of expensive
when you're doing a lot of them you are
participating to something which is
helping you at the end of the day epping
your film so so so I chose and way I
chose these festivals is I knew dancing
with Eames the type of films they were
screening and it was perfectly to right
target for for Pink Zone same thing for
action of him which is more of a genre
of film festival and now we have so many
I mean at the same time as we chose this
one we just learned that we got into
fenders portal which is one of the
greatest general film festival in Europe
and who basically screening the top
third genre films in in in the world and
we got in because they trust they have
this way of doing things where they show
the must talk about general movies of
the year at the same time as they take
leap of faith for small genre films like
us and so
the each film will find its own home and
of course not every festivals are for
every fear of course you have to know
which room you made you have to know
what is going to be your audience and
once you know that you can target
precisely the kind of festivals you want
to go into Ben how hard was it for you
to find investors for Pink Zone well I
have to say I could eat a no budget
which is because we had to spend like
i'd say between 5,000 and 6,000 which is
no budget in terms of of moviemaking and
they were all private savings so so we
we went and make the movie with
literally no phones and no one involved
so so so in a way it was it was making
us if you are free and but I mean I
think that even though that was the
story of this movie I would tell young
filmmakers not to be afraid of getting
money you have to go and get the money
where it is out there so so so getting
investors is not a bad thing it is not
going to ruin your creative vision on
the contrary I think that the best on
the contrary it can be seen as a limit
but if you are as serious and as good as
if you Mike area you will always find a
way to go around that and you to tell
your story this or you have your heart
in your mind so I don't think that would
be a limit even when a a lot of people
are putting money from everywhere and
then ask for people to for certain kind
of things but it's like every other
limit on a movie set up I mean when
you're making V there are a lot of
limits and there are a lot of obstacles
and you just have to go around it around
the mountain and just find a way to just
continue and keep telling the story so
no crowdfunding you didn't want to try
her hand at that Wow was it about it the
thing was because we were just wanted to
shoot that fast that we had the money
there sleeping for us so so we just went
out and made the movie and we didn't
want to to wait too long for crowd
family and to and to put our hopes on
hold you know it's like when you're when
you're doing crowdfunding you it's great
but you you can also be waiting longer
and longer than expected and then the
level of interest for the story and
commitment is getting down and down and
down so whereas for pings oh it was kind
of a yeah for me the reference in the
way we did these film is Roger common we
just went indeed Roger common we cannot
film with just no budget and just shut
it for the sake of the story with just
the help of friends and our private
savings for your next film which I know
your your plans crime drama thank you do
you plan to do a bigger budget yeah okay
yeah for me this one was primarily to
bring them to can make teeth in and the
next one the way I'm writing it right
now is on a much bigger scale and even
though it's very grant into reality it
will involve much more money so so I'm
open to any kind of investments can be
can go from crime funny to private
investors it's we would go where who
will be interested to to finance it do
you plan on on mapping that out like do
you know certain people that you can ask
or do you plan let's launch the
crowdfunding campaign and then maybe
sometimes investors will match certain
things I mean do you
an idea yeah I I know that with
especially with the film festivals where
imprisoning pings on right now a lot of
people are asking me okay what's next
and I'm talking about them about the
story and I so I made these people who
are because they stopping son and loved
it so much they are committed to maybe
help finds the next one and so that's
why this movie also is great as a way to
engage people to finance the next one
and that's why also for the next film
festivals we're going to do with beams
own especially the big ones in your rap
we're gonna steal continue present pings
on as a way to finance the next one your
cast for Pink Zone very young attractive
cast what made you choose that cast I
chose that cast because I wanted to have
people who were fresh and new and could
experiment with their characters with
improvisation because I relied a lot on
improvisation and without no judgment on
their characters and that's what I love
about them that they had no preconceived
ideas about their own characters and
each single day when they came on set I
was being able to direct them in a way
they could take from their own life too
and build the characters in a much
closer way to them your approach working
with an actress versus an actor I know
with actresses I'm a woman we're
concerned with the way we look so they
take a little longer sometimes to get
ready and they're more concerned with
certain things so your approach with an
actress versus an actor I you know as I
have to say I worked with them both with
no different approach at all for me they
were their characters I had a different
approach for each actor because a lot of
the actress worked in a different way
and so I'm tuning my my approach as a
director to each actor or rather than
male and girls and so and so now all the
girls were so committed they didn't lose
any time just like
this myth of a hair-and-makeup everybody
was just so committed and there was no
time for there was literally no time for
small things like that